all right this is really cool it's a
special Tuesday edition of our seen and
unseen segment what we expose the big
cultural stories of the day talks turkey
Bernie twirls into a revolution and
Baltimore mistreats the first lady
joining us with all the details Raymond
Arroyo Fox News contributor all right
Raymond the president today spent some
quality time with a few feathered
friends and I'm not talking about Pelosi
and Schiff
what happened Laura today was the annual
presidential turkey pardon love at two
birds bread and butter were flown into
DC by the national Turkey Federation and
they were put up at the Willard hotel
wouldn't you love to be the maid
cleaning up that right yeah once again
the White House posted stats on the two
turkeys and allowed the public to decide
which bird should get the pardon but
before the big unveil the president used
the occasion to pluck his political
opponents bread and butter have been
specially raised by the Jacksons to
remain calm under any condition which
will be very important because they've
already received subpoenas to appear in
Adam shifts basement on Thursday unlike
previous witnesses you and I have
actually met this is great this is his
great weapon really politically his
sense of humor that no one really can
answer you don't have anyone in the
opposing party who can mount that kind
of uh meet him on a level of humor and
connect with the audience then the
president got down to business Laura
butter let's talk to you for a second
because I'm gonna do something did you
get to be very happy about butter I wish
you a lot of luck
I hereby grant you a full and complete
pardon okay butter
what happened to bread Laura oh there is
nothing
I think they fed him to Jerrold Nadler
they're trying to you know keep him at
bay a little for a little bit or maybe
conan the anti-terrorism dog had a
little Thanksgiving treat you know
here's a little butter for you what did
the other turkey really not get pardoned
all right now I'm concerned about this
it wasn't there the other one was not
there so it who knows it would be
grilling in the White House kitchen as
we speak oh no Tommy just said he's a
backup oh okay we got to get going
this is a tough floor go what well I got
to tell you about Bernie Sanders okay he
had he had a heart scare back in October
so he's being careful not exerting
himself right right that's right but now
he's showing voters in New Hampshire
that he still got the stuff Laura the 78
year old socialist became the dancing
King the other night and the Labour
solidarity dinner in Manchester at least
they had fair warning our revolution our
revolution includes dancing and when a
buck started playing the revolution
began Bernie did the cha-cha with a
series of supporters and later he
tweeted out he was having the time of
his life Laura I mean since these poll
numbers have been so below and eroding
in some places and the Obama machine is
now against him he might have better
prospects over a Dancing with the Stars
Wow do you think he'd get all the
opposition that that poor old sir got I
don't think that probably I think Bernie
was a really good dancer I'm a bit of a
dance snob myself okay shame right now
in front of the judges of Dancing with
the Stars oh good you know I thought he
was very I thought he was very good on
his feet I thought he was actually that
that was the best thing I've seen him
done I do ever thanks guys I have to
share perhaps toast embarrassing video
of the day and this is serious
embarrassing for the Baltimore County
today 2500 high school and middle school
kids in Baltimore attended a youth
summit on opioid addiction and the first
lady intended to talk to them about the
opioid epidemic she
is greeted this way the first lady
United States
[Applause]
Raymond let me just say this these
people are so ill-informed I want to put
it kindly on this holiday season and
they're so angry or they're just so
brainwash but whatever the top line is
they read on Facebook whatever that they
don't realize that they're actually
helping President Trump and the first
lady by their ungracious reaction they
don't like them you know don't vote for
me those are school kids
these are subliminal kids somebody is
somebody is prompting them somebody's
teaching them that it's okay to go out
and Boo harass a First Lady this way I'm
sorry
I would I would have opposed this if
they did it to Michelle Obama absolute
or any first lady you want to protest
the president have at it but to boo a
first lady who's there to help you in
the middle of an opioid epidemic yeah
that sounds a bit of the first lady's
message here house kids law that evolve
and be a part of the solution if we
continue to work hand in hand I know we
will be able to achieve amazing things
I'm in this fight with you and I'm
fighting for you I want to say Raymond
good for her she should do more
interviews and more appearances because
every time she does she does so with
grace and beauty and and this was at
just a wonderful and needed message and
she shows the country what real class is
she should do more interviews and not in
any way retreat because of an ungracious
Rand not that she would but you know I'm
saying that there was the principal
where's an adult getting on stage saying
you anyone booing get out I was the
principal and teacher running these
schools they need to be taught manners
and pass it on to their students it was
obnoxious and horrible today I see the
the gentleman on stage before the first
lady you know he seemed like pretty
casually dressed I mean there was a day
people would actually wear that with
Mark Wahlberg's brother who was part of
it's all sense it all sends a message
I'm glad he was there and did a nice
introduction but it would have been he's
pretty cool he got up there and say guys
knock it off that's what we said Raymond
have a great Thanksgiving and
we'll see you on Friday for Friday
Follies and you're gonna be hosting for
me tomorrow night
so everybody tune in to watch the rain
it's gonna be an awesome show